state your name are you trying to  conduct it interview yeah is that  Alright  sure I'm game please state your name how  about Tony Tony your name is Tony I  believe a person is right to be called  whatever they want to be called very  well then  Tony it is actually I changed my mind  how about Richard that's fine with me  Richard it is what's the next question  why do you threaten Foundation personnel  threatened who is making threats  you've predicted a number of unfortunate  events involving the foundation  including the end of the world there's  any harm that create coverage  you murdered agent Baxter doctor I  believe you have the wrong impression  about me also I am NOT the bad guy here  I wasn't aware there was a bad guy  involved who scp-294 of I there is no  SCP with that designation and there  won't be for some time well of course  not she hasn't even been born yet much  less classified by her foundation is  this another prediction and this is your  wake-up call  you